graph f of x on the given domain so f of
x is equal to four times the absolute
value of x plus six
minus eight and the domain is x between
negative eight including negative eight
this bracket means that we're going to
include this endpoint and negative 2 and
we're going to include negative 2. the
bracket means we're going to include it
if we didn't want to include the
endpoints we would use parentheses what
are the coordinates of the vertex so
let's think about the vertex first the
vertex you can kind of view it as the
corner of an absolute value function and
so it's either going to be the maximum
point or the minimum point of the
function
now over here let's just think about it
a little bit when would this hit a
maximum or a minimum point well we know
that the absolute value of something is
always going to be non-negative it could
be zero that's why i'm not saying that
it could always be it's always going to
be positive it's going to be
non-negative so we have something that's
non-negative right over here and then
we're multiplying it times something
that is positive so this thing the whole
expression over here non-negative times
a positive is always going to be
non-negative so it's either going to be
0 or greater so this thing is always
going to be adding to the value of f of
x so the minimum value of f of x happens
when this whole thing is 0 and then when
this whole thing is 0 then f of x is
negative 8. that is the minimum value
any other for any other x at any other
point this thing is going to be larger
than zero
so let's just think about when does this
whole thing equal zero well this whole
thing is going to be equaling is
equaling zero if x plus six is equal to
zero and when does x plus six equal zero
well when x is equal to negative six
when x is negative six then this whole
thing is zero and f of x is equal to
negative eight
so that's the vertex and that's going to
be the minimum point this is going to be
an upward opening absolute value
function so now let's just draw it and
what we could do is we could put some
points at the vertex so let's put let's
put some points let's see negative 6 8
negative 6 negative 8 negative 6
negative 8 is right over there let me
scroll down make sure you can see that
point
negative 6 negative 8 is right over
there and i actually want to make you
see the function definition as well and
let's just think about what it does at
the boundaries on either side it's going
to be a line so when
x is negative 8 what is this x what is f
of x negative 8 plus 6
is negative 2 take the absolute value of
that that is going to be 2 times 4 is 8
minus 8 is 0. so you have the point
negative 8 comma 0.
and then let's think about what happens
at the other boundary when x is negative
negative 2 plus 6
is
the absolute value of 4 is 4 4 times 4
is going to be 16 minus 8 is 8. so it's
going to be the point negative two
negative two
eight
just like that and i think we're done
yes we are